[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Marta Moya me acompaña en el
estudio como todas las mañanas Marta
bienvenida buena mañana de miércoles
empezamos hoy no en nuestra región
porque ayer el gobierno de Colombia
anunció el reinicio finalmente de las
conversaciones con la guerrilla del Ln
luego de la que la administración
anterior del ex presidente Iván Duque
hubiera cerrado cualquier posibilidad de
estas negociaciones veamos Entonces como
lo titula la prensa colombiana empezando
con el colombiano hace Raúl buenos días
empezamos con el colombiano que titula
este miércoles por quinta vez se intenta
la paz con el eln las negociaciones se
quedaron en
standby en 2019 cuando Iván Duque cerró
toda la posibilidad de diálogo con la
guerrilla después de un atentado en una
escuela de policías y ahora pues el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro izquierdista a
bueno ha cumplido o ha empezado a
cumplir una de sus promesas de campaña
que es pues este reinicio de los
diálogos las primeras semanas de
noviembre serán el escenario para
empezar estas conversaciones y bueno es
una historia repetida porque es la
quinta vez que se reinician estas
conversaciones se busca una salida
negociada con esta guerrilla después de
58 años de conflicto y lln todavía tiene
a casi
5.400 miembros en activo las novedades
son que no hay una ciudad o un país fijo
para estos diálogos que serán
conversaciones itinerantes y que
Venezuela Cuba Chile España y Noruega
serán los países grandes
el espectador titula así llegan el
gobierno y el eln a la nueva mesa de
negociación el escenario es muy distinto
al de 2018 cuando Iván Duque llegó a la
presidencia de la República porque él no
mostró ningún tipo de voluntad de
diálogo con esta guerrilla por la parte
Estatal Pues el primer gobierno de
izquierdas Y esto es una condición
también favorable al interno del eln
Duque pues llegó a decir que quería
revisar estos diálogos pero sin embargo
nunca y Petro ya en campaña había dicho
que pues quería iniciar estas
conversaciones para buscar esa Paz total
ron que busca la hoja de ruta pues no
está definida por parte del gobierno y
después por parte de la guerrilla pues
son conscientes de que este primer
gobierno de izquierdas puede ser Incluso
el último y es una un deseo como Ahora o
nunca no es bueno el Ln está más
fortificado después de la desaparición
de las FARC y bueno dicen que hay
choques entre el área militar y el área
política y esto puede generar tensiones
en el devenir de las conversaciones Qué
dice Marta la editorial del tiempo el
tiempo titula eln el nuevo intento dice
este editorial que no hay margen de
error para repetir los errores valga la
redundancia del pasado en esta
reanudación del diálogo que es
fundamental que la sociedad colombiana
vea avances y vea bueno los verdaderos
gestos por la paz de esta guerrilla
después de El fracaso de los otros
cuatro y que hay la necesidad de pactar
una metodología que permita que pronto
se vean estos resultados además dice que
tiene que haber en el centro del diálogo
pues la reparación la verdad y las
garantías de no repetición y sobre todo
que tampoco sean los delitos más atroces
que ha cometido esta guerrilla
continuamos nuestro repaso Marta por la
prensa internacional ahora hablamos de
la sequías en el estado de California en
Estados Unidos que suman tres años
consecutivos y las perspectivas para lo
que viene tampoco son alentadoras si
Raúl abrimos con el legardien que titula
la sequía de tres años en California
continúa sin alivio a la vista la mayor
parte del Estado está en un estado valga
la redundancia también de sequía extrema
y esto ha sido el caldo de cultivo para
incendios forestales de Gran en verdad
envergadura y bueno se han agotado los
recursos hídricos se espera un año seco
por delante en el sur del Estado pues no
podrán recibir mucha más agua de la que
se necesita para beber o para bañarse y
bueno Pese a que la reducción de agua en
el mes de agosto ya ha sido Del 10,5%
pues es todavía insuficiente y esto
supone también un problema para los
agricultores que pueden ver pues
perjudicados sus cultivos rápidamente
Marta el país el país titula a
California entra en su cuarto año de
sequía con poca esperanza de mejoría
dice pues que estos últimos tres años
han sido los más secos desde que hay
registros desde 1896 y que con el nuevo
calendario para los expertos las
expectativas son muy bajas y que bueno
aunque este mes de septiembre ha habido
grandes precipitaciones los recursos
están por debajo del 70%. cerramos con
un análisis del orden mundial que
destaca que Europa no haría bien
encerrarle las puertas a las fronteras a
los ciudadanos rusos que huyen de los
llamados al frente de batalla Marta esto
nos abre la puerta para nuestra primera
invitada al día así a Raúl el orden
mundial es un análisis de Alba Leiva
titula Europa se equivoca cerrando las
fronteras rusos que huyen de Putin las
divisiones al interno de la unión como
siempre
diversidad de opiniones por ejemplo
letonia Estonia Polonia han cerrado
frontera República Checa y Finlandia se
lo están pensando zelenski pidió que se
cerraran las fronteras para bueno hacer
presión a Vladimir Putin Y bueno
celenski pues tiene que entender que
Vladimir Putin controla los medios de
comunicación en Rusia y que esto Bueno
pues serviría como también un mecanismo
de propaganda por su parte pues Bruselas
ya ha endurecido los mecanismos de
presión a Vladimir Putin poniendo
condiciones a los visados pero que no
hay consenso porque Charles Michelle por
ejemplo dice que se vería abrir la
puerta a los ciudadanos que huyen de
Putin o el canciller Alemán Hola shells
habla de que por cuestiones humanitarias
deberían bueno estos ciudadanos poder
entrar a la Unión Europea Marta quede
con nosotros o para seguir analizando